cyberpunk 2077 gets the unreal 5
treatment gta is off to a great start
and more
since it was officially released last
month unreal engine 5 has been used to
create some impressive projects the
latest example comes from youtuber and
developer infant terrible who put
together a sizzle reel of content that
reimagines cyberpunk 2077's night city
within epic software a number of artists
helped create the project with the
following talents contributing to the
tech demo apologies for any
mispronunciations so here tariq lay art
studios js films art core studios
musashi imagawa artem artificial jhill
and infraction the artists use
environment mega packs from the epic
marketplace to recreate night city and
populate it with characters from epics
the meta humans creator and additional
work was done in zbrush and vfx i'll
include a link to the full video in the
description but also what does one have
to do to become this talented i'm asking
for a friend but speaking of free
roaming in a crime-filled city let's
talk about grand theft auto back in
march of 2022 take two interactive
rolled out gta plus an optional paid
subscription service for gta online the
initial announcement was met with some
mixed reactions from fans but according
to take two the service is apparently
doing well in a recent earnings call for
the fiscal period that ended on march
31st ceo strauss zelnick said the
company is thrilled with the number of
players who have signed up for gta plus
gta plus is currently only available on
the playstation 5 and xbox series x and
s and costs six dollars per month for
extra bonuses and cash infusions
subscribers get 500 000 gta bucks
discounts bonus rewards from certain
events and free cosmetic items you can
head over to gamespot.com and check out
our write-up analyzing of gta plus is
worth it for the month of april comment
below if you're a gta plus subscriber
and what you like most about it and now
let's switch gears to a game without
petty street crimes millennia is without
a doubt the hardest boss in elden ring
so how does she fare when pitted against
every other major boss in the game the
answer very well soul's boring content
creator garden of eyes has created a mod
that pits the game's various bosses
against one another and it's clear in a
new video from the creator that
millennia is a cut above the rest there
are however a few bosses that give
millennia a run for her money largely
towards the end of the game we won't
spoil which bosses prove to be a
challenge or if any of them actually
managed to defeat millennia but it's fun
to see some of eldon ring's most
challenging enemies also struggle with
the same enemy that has seen players
resort to summoning help like let me
solo her in order to overcome and before
we close out i wanted to remind you to
mark your calendars because fall guys is
finally heading to xbox and nintendo
switch on june 1st and the game is
adopting a free to play business model
full cross play and cross progression
will be supported across xbox and switch
as well as ps4 and ps5 thanks to the
game using epic's online services this
news got a little overshadowed by the
playstation plus news yesterday but it's
still very exciting nonetheless i can't
wait to jump back in and watch my
brother-in-law experience it for the
first time let me know if this june will
be your first time playing fall guys or
if you're a lapsed player like me and
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]